this is R both
said that's hi I'm Lisa Anne Walter
hello I'm Quinta Brunson hi I'm shery
Ralph hello Janelle James I'm Tyler
James Williams I'm William Stanford
Davis I'm Chris Peretti and we are the
cast of Abbot Elementary and we are here
with BuzzFeed to take a quiz to see
which character from Abbott we actually
[Music]
are what was your favorite subject in
school ma math Engish engl history art
science is that drama drama I don't
know stand what English real favorite
recess I'm going with history I'm doing
art a honor English oh okay all right
now they don't have that
option someone's literate your best
quality as a teacher would be patience a
can do attitude humor leadership
creativity
honestly everything about me you that I
think beautifully it's not patience I
know that I say patience I'm going to go
with humor leadership I'm going with
humor I feel like honestly everything
about me is both the Barbara and the
Cheryl answer I'm so afraid of getting
Janine that I don't want to click um
things but I'm going to do patience okay
pick two picking Abbot Elementary
character to spend the day with Tariq
Gary Zack Aisha Ashley or Amber I'm g go
Tariq I'm going Tariq I'm going Tariq
team Tariq I feel bad now I didn't pick
Gary I know feel guilty who's an
important Philly thing the 76ers yeah
mine is cheese Saks I wish I had one
right now yeah the Eagles I'm so hungry
Franklin Institute and the Philadelphia
Zoo which has a picture of me in
it wait that's hilarious a picture of us
too yeah the Franklin in going Franklin
Institute I'm going Eagles
yeah go I'm going gritty I'm you would
go gritty go gritty or go home wait did
you pick one cuz you're from Philly
listen I pick the Eagles you piic the
eag it oh you're going to be pick a
fictional teacher to hang out with Mr
feny from Boy Meets World anelise keing
from How To Get Away With Murder Jessica
Dave from New Girl Miss Frizzle from The
Magic School Bus Mr Garvey from Key and
Peele oh absolutely Mr Garvey from I
know so good Mr rat bur from I'mma go Mr
Fe Mr I love Mr these are all way after
my time did not watch TV I was out stand
up these
years I'll go with Mr Garvey from K
going you going
anise will wild frle will be fun you can
go up somebody's butthole
exactly get a day off how do you spend
it doing more work it never stops at the
spa cook a delicious meal visit a museum
a day off is just a state of mind that I
what is that choose to be in every day
um or wait one more hitting the gym none
of
my I'm going cooking a delicious meal
I'm going to wind up being Melissa you
said hitting the gym wow yeah cuz it's
so hard to get in after work you know
what it really wow what a Gregory thing
I know I really hate that I'll be at the
spa I'll be at the spa too I'll I'm not
going to lie I'll be at the spa I love a
SP love the SP dude I love I want to go
to the spot today really I mean I would
if I could but we're here oh that's true
yeah which is fun wow look what you're
doing to his bus
be snack to get you through the day
Apple a breakfast sandwich you best
believe uh Melissa's BR snack Wells Ola
bar wine because it's 5:00 somewhere
Zeno a snack I think think about how you
cut it up and eat it throughout the day
it could make for a good source of
protein and with a salad
just I am damn it I'm Gregory E okay
wait she got Janine that's rude you're
Gregory she said e I'm also Gregory yeah
oh my God I got Melissa shime I'm
Melissa
shim all right
like to hear we don't know yet St has
like 10 more questions weirdly what we
been doing this all time I got Barbara
Howard that's so weird hilarious I got
jine which means this game is
[Music]
[Laughter]
broken what you get oh he's also a
Janine this is we both said I'm Melissa
shenti what answer got you that I I
haven't the slightest idea I don't did
you pick Grano yes I did there you go
that's why well listen that's a great
source of protein it protein that with
salad like Melissa you're a seasoned vet
who'd instantly be everyone's favorite
second grade teacher sorry that's okay
you're helpful and kind but you're also
no nonsense and you'll admit I'm going
into her accent you're not above
occasionally messing with your
colleagues and friends at the end of the
day it's all in good fun hey you've been
doing this job a long time and you may
as well get some laughs out of it you
have been doing a job a long time you
might as well get some laughs out of it
yeah I feel like that I feel like the
most like your character you're the most
like do you think absolutely but I am
acting you guys no you aren't she's
acting her ass off I got Gregory Eddie
you're a great person and hardworking
but still haven't exactly gone according
to your no that's not true things have
all gone according to my plans so that's
not true I think I feel like a Gregory
like Janine you're an
idealist a huge heart a and you want to
do all you want to do is help people
especially your students true you'll
never quit on others because you don't
want others to quit on that's right oh I
like it that's right twin also BuzzFeed
excellent job with that
Janine straight from I am obviously
Barbara H um I'm not going to read the
whole thing but it does say simply put
your
excellent love
it excellent TI I have now taken this
quiz three times and changed my answer
and every single time is Gregory
Edie that's why you were so quiet up
there this whole time I don't have a
pass code too apparently regardless of
how I choose to live my life this is my
destiny I guess there you have it thank
you BuzzFeed make sure you check out
Abid Elementary February 7th on
ABC the next day on Hulu yes you can
also catch previous seasons on HB Max in
other countries you can find I'm
[Music]
kidding